I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense pure science
this is astronomy well let's go back so
you like you said it's been around for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years and so when I look at astrology
from a skeptical point of view you know
I'm like well what does it really mean
but then I always like my mind always
goes to the fact that it's been around
longer than like anything it's always
been here look at the Egyptians and
understand stars and and understand seas
every time they were in the ocean they
had to guide themselves from place to
place it was always based on the Stars
so where did it I mean where does this
come from where does astrology originate
I'm gonna say the weirdest thing but I
have to say i trolled a little bit and
saw your little last interview I think
it was downloaded from a higher
intelligence I'll let you guess what I'm
imagining
yeah like it was brought to us by an
intelligence that's clearly not ours
like it's so airtight it's such a clean
system I can tell you the timing I can
tell you the personality type and it
always works I came as a skeptic so the
really yeah I I was just curious trained
just look I have a master - how old were
you when you started then I started when
I was the first time I ever had a
reading I was 18 as well oh yeah I was
just but I came with this question mark
like is this real I have a logical mind
which is why I teach and talk it's so
easy I a lot of Earth so I'm super
practical but over the years now there's
no question and so I kept asking this
question like who is so intelligent
psychologically to describe these
they're very distinct personality types
with such clarity the body part the
timing the personality type the way
they'll act in the fight the way they'll
act when they're sad the way that they
want to go approach money the way they
want to go approach exercise like I
could describe by you giving me a
character exactly how they're gonna and
it's always accurate it's like being
psychic it has shades of psychic I would
say yes it does have shades of pink
you're so cute
it does have shades of being psychic it
does lead into a right brain function it
starts off that's how I was saying it's
pure science like this is astronomy this
is not debatable when you were born the
Sun and the moon were in the same spot
you know that
you were born under a dark sky so I
automatically know you're an introvert
even though you're a double aries and
you've got all this fire party you you
were born under a completely dark sky so
I mean you know she likes going in
I had a personality test done this year
and not just like when you take online
but a professional one where there's you
know an hour session afterwards to go
through it and so in it there's three
different categories one is your social
setting and how you are in casual
situations and then there's another
category of sort of your work scenario
so more of your decision-making skills
sort of in business how you operate your
control is what they call that category
and then the final category is your
affection category which is your deep
relationships and your romantic
relationships and interested in the
social setting my there's two different
parts within each three and there's an
expressed amount and then there's a
wanted amount and it's a scale from zero
to nine so in a social setting which is
casual don't know you very well small
talk I express a two out of nine and you
know how much I want zero zero I don't I
can take vacations by myself I like to
be alone a lot I'm here I can't oh yeah
how so how do you because it shows up
with your son this is one of the quotes
that I use when I teach whatever house
the Sun falls in describes the whole
theme of the chart cuz that house is lit
up like whatever part of the sky the Sun
was in so when you were born it was just
getting passed to the horizon it was
going down and it was in the house of
the loner so that's funny because you're
so the rest of your chair it is
unbelievably social like your social
skills and your grace and your charm and
everyone falls in love with you because
you got this little Libra and you look
so cute we can dress you up but there's
a pretty girls for fake but but it's but
it still looks good but your secret
sauce is Shh can we go now
you